Speaker 1: Well, ladies and gentlemen, he
did it last night.
A wet and glistening Donald Trump announced
his 2024 presidential run to a crowd of sort
of bored people.
Quite frankly, that's one of the storylines
from Mar a Lago, which will get to a little
bit later, but a very different energy last
night than in times past.
Trump himself even seemed kind of bored with
the speech he was reading off of his teleprompter.
The crowd only engaged at a few moments and
remember that many people around Trump were
telling him as recently as Monday, You should
not do this.
You should not do this after the results of
the 2022 midterms.
You should not do this after the realization
that this isn't even really over 2022 elections
until December six, with the runoff in Georgia
and Donald Trump deciding to do it.
Now, many of you will remember our friend
Michael Cohen, Trump's former lawyer, swore
up and down to me, Trump's not going to run.
Many others, even in my audience, were emailing
me as recently as yesterday morning saying,
Trump's not going to run, he is running, and
we are now going to have another potentially
two years of insanity in the United States.
Now, before we get to the clips, another aspect
to this that I believe, especially with the
energy behind Ron DeSantis, may be very different
than in 2016 and in 2020, is that you are
going to see the people behind Donald Trump,
especially those who get behind him this early,
on average, be even more extreme because there
are now other options, including Ron DeSantis,
who hasn't declared that he's running for
anything and is already leading Trump in most
polls taken after the November 8th midterms,
all of which we will get to CNN and FOX News
initially covered Trump's speech live.
They eventually cut away.
We're going to get to that as well.
MSNBC ignored it completely.
I tried to cover it.
We had technical issues which I will address
a little bit later.
I got some really nasty emails about it, but
I will get to that.
But let's start off with already.
I mean, just even the way Donald Trump was
welcomed into the room was absurd.
Speaker 2: Gentlemen, please welcome the next
president.
Speaker 1: And first lady of the United States.
Speaker 3: Of America, President Donald.
Speaker 2: J. Trump, accompanied.
Speaker 1: By Mrs. Melania Trump.
And I'm glad to be an American.
Okay.
So just completely horrifying from the get
go.
The most high energy moment from the entire
thing was the moment that Donald Trump actually
announced.
Speaker 4: In order to make America great
and glorious again.
I am tonight announcing my candidacy for president
of the United States.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So the crowd certainly engaged there, but
at almost no other time, Donald Trump was
expected to go at the most half an hour.
He went nearly a full hour and got into some
of the same old tired stuff, including this
completely bonkers, dictatorial idea of executing
every drug dealer like they do in China.
Speaker 4: Answerable for death, carnage and
crime all over our country.
Every drug dealer during his or her life on
average will kill 500 people with the drugs
they sell.
Not to mention the destruction of families.
But we're going to be asking everyone who
sells drugs, gets caught selling drugs to
receive the death penalty for their heinous
acts.
Speaker 1: Even that language is so funny.
We're going to ask the drug dealers to receive
the death penalty.
Mr. Drug Dealer.
Sir, we would like you to receive the death
penalty, please, because.
Speaker 4: It's the only way.
We don't need any more blue ribbon committees.
We don't need I don't like to say this and
I don't even know if the American public is
ready for it.
And a lot of my people say, please don't say
that, sir, that's not nice.
They kill 500 people each year on average.
And if you don't do this in China, when I
was with President Xi, I said, President,
do you have a drug problem?
No, no, no, no, we don't.
Speaker 1: That's Trump's impersonation of
Xi.
No, no, no, no.
So, listen, this is this is a wacky idea.
And again, not mincing words.
This is an authoritarian extremist.
He would like the United States to be even
more authoritarian, but he's also a liar and
a hypocrite because Donald Trump pardoned
many drug dealers at the end of his presidency.
So death penalty for drug dealers also Trump
pardoning drug dealers.
At another moment during the speech, clearly
gearing up for what is going to be a contentious
battle with other Republicans, it's abundantly
clear that's going to be the case during this
new presidential run.
Donald Trump actually sort of going after
the Republican Party, but laying out a very
bleak situation.
Speaker 4: Much criticism is being placed
on the fact that the Republican Party should
have done better.
And frankly, much of this blame is correct.
But the citizens of our country have not yet
realized the full extent and gravity of the
pain our nation is going through, and the
total effect of the suffering is just starting
to take hold.
Speaker 1: You're going to suffer much, much
more, ladies and gentlemen.
But you can also vote for me and I'll fix
everything, even though I fixed nothing last
time.
And this is part of why I think this time
it may not go so well for Trump, but we'll
get to that.
Speaker 4: Don't quite feel it yet, but they
will very soon.
I have no doubt that by 2024 it will sadly
be much worse and they will see much more
clearly what happened and what is happening
to our country.
Speaker 1: Yeah, by by the time you get the
opportunity to vote for me, Trump says, things
are really going to be bad.
Another kind of weird interlude and a strange
thing to include in a presidential announcement.
Trump saying again that we're going to go
to Mars.
At least he pronounced it correctly this time.
Remember that viral moment previously where
Trump said, We are going to put a man on?
Nars He at least got it right this time.
Speaker 4: Human knowledge and extend the
horizons of human achievement.
And we will plant our beautiful American flag
very soon on the surface of Mars, which I
guess.
Speaker 1: The crowd is sort of like, Yeah,
I guess so.
Trump said he got that started, which is,
of course, not true.
A very weird thing.
Trump also choosing to float a new conspiracy
theory during this announcement that maybe
China is the one that stole the 2020 elections
from him.
Remember, he's tried everything else.
It was the Democrats.
It was communists, communists, communists,
communists, socialists, Marxists, all of whom
don't really exist in the United States.
It was, you know, Hunter Biden's laptop, whatever.
Now it's been this is very irresponsible.
Now, it might have been China.
Speaker 4: Many people think that because
of this, China played a very active role in
the 2020 election.
Just saying just say, sure, that didn't happen.
Speaker 1: All right.
You know, like two people clapping.
And what is becoming very clear about this
new run, which of course it will be another
grift run for Trump to raise money is the
strategy will be lie about all the things
he he supposedly did as president, claim everything
was amazing when he was president and then
claim that again, we need him to prevent things
from being terrible, which they will be under
Joe Biden, I guess at another moment.
I know, guys, it's you look at the calendar
and you say.
Is my calendar right?
Is it November of 2022?
Is it almost 2023?
And Trump is still talking about Hillary Clinton's
emails, which he, by the way, pronounces Clinton,
which is a whole other story.
Yes, you would be right.
He's still talking about that.
Speaker 4: Including the raid of a very beautiful
house that sits right here, the rate of monologue,
I think of it and I say, Why didn't you read
Bush's place?
Why didn't you read Clinton 30,000 emails?
Why didn't you raid Clinton's place?
Why didn't you do?
Obama took a lot of things with him.
We owe Batman the wreck.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So I didn't.
I know Trump claims to be religious, and we
know that he's not.
Maybe this is the Festivus airing of grievances
that Donald Trump was doing, and he did indeed
straight up just say, I'm a victim.
I'm a very big victim.
Thank you.
Speaker 4: And I'm a victim.
I will tell you, I'm a victim.
Thick of it.
Thank.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: Surprising to some, but not to
others.
Donald Trump did include portions of the transphobic
sections of his recent rally speeches and
his big announcement yesterday.
Pay attention to something is notable about
this part.
Speaker 4: We were doing.
We were starting to really get it right.
We will not let men, as an example, participate
in women's sports.
Is that okay?
No.
Unidentified: No men.
No men.
Speaker 1: Now the crowd is engaged.
Speaker 4: My people tell me.
Sure, that's politically incorrect to say.
I said, that's okay.
I'll say it anyway, if you don't mind.
Speaker 1: So much like with CPAC recently,
the transphobia and homophobia were the most
interesting moments of CPAC speeches to that
crowd other than when Trump said, I'm running
for president.
This was an hour speech.
The crowd was mostly dead.
Dead.
They tried to leave.
They weren't allowed.
We'll get to that.
The most interesting speech, moments of the
speech to the crowd were when Trump said,
I'm running and when Trump said no men in
women's sports.
So that tells us quite a bit.
One other thing, Donald Trump blamed the Green
New Deal for all sorts of things.
There is no green New Deal.
The Green New Deal isn't law.
It's just a proposal really bad.
Speaker 4: The socialist disaster known as
the Green New Deal, which is destroying our
country and the many crippling regulations
that it has spawned, will be immediately terminated
so that our country can again breathe and
grow and thrive like it should.
Speaker 1: Yeah, the crowd maybe with tepid
applause because there is no green New Deal
to end the green.
New Deal is a proposal, but the Green New
Deal is not the law.
So the crowd clearly confused.
And then here is the end of Donald Trump's
speech.
The crowd just barely into it.
Trump doing, you know, a version of the same
way he's ended his recent rally speeches.
Speaker 4: We will make America Strong Again.
We will make America proud again.
We will make America safe again.
We will make America glorious again.
Speaker 1: That's a little extra addition.
Speaker 4: And we will make America great
again.
Thank you very much.
God bless you all.
Thank you.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So, listen.
A very different speech than at any prior
time.
This is going to be a very different sort
of candidacy for Donald Trump.
There are options.
There are strong options.
There are many Republicans who are already
sick of this guy.
And and and and there is a completely different
dynamic in the United States with what the
Republican Party electorate looks like.
So this is only the beginning.
We are going to be with you for the entire
thing.
2024 clearly starts now, earlier than ever.
The best thing you can do.
Make sure you subscribe to our podcast.
Make sure you subscribe to the YouTube channel
and be with us for the coverage and we will
see where the country ends up.
There are more than 3 million viewers of ours
who watch the clips but aren't subscribed
on YouTube.
Make sure you hit that subscribe button.
It's a very easy thing to do